do you think right now you're the best
cornerback in football i know i am
you're sure 100
will you get paid like that
yeah i will
do you think you'll
play your whole career in jacksonville
maybe
[Laughter]
that was a loaded answer from jaylen
ramsey to peter king and
a step or two beyond the maybe would be
if you're not playing in jacksonville
where you'll be playing and jaylen
ramsey appearing on the bussing with the
boys podcast featuring titan's tackle
taylor lawn and former linebacker will
compton he said that if he leaves
jacksonville he'd probably play in
nashville with the titans or in las
vegas with the raiders so i i as darren
gant of pft characterized it in the
story he wrote today jaylen ramsey is
tampering with himself by linking
himself to these teams you rarely hear a
guy talk openly about where he would
want to play when he's currently under
contract with one nfl team but you know
what jalen ramsey does his own thing and
unless and until they pay him they run
the risk of him trying to make like an
nba player and dictate his future
absolutely but i those were two
surprising picks from for for me from
him you don't normally hear players
going i want to play for the titans
especially i understand the raiders a
little bit more but
maybe he wants to go play for mike
brabel who knows but yeah he's probably
going to end up dictating where he goes
in free agency i would i would think
unless they franchise tag him betrayed
him i don't think he's going to end up
back in jacksonville once he is headed
toward free agency he grew up in
nashville so that would be the most
obvious connection because yeah unless
and also you know hey it's an
opportunity to stick it to the jaguars
right they're in the division you play
them twice a year i'm surprised he
didn't throw in the colts and the texans
as well but uh his situation is he's got
a 13.7 million dollar option for 2020
and then the franchise tag comes into
play 2021 2022 that's when the jaguars
will have to decide do they spend big
money on him do they try to sign the
long-term deal to do a tag and trade or
do they eventually just let him walk
away to nashville las vegas or somewhere
else
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports